professor gupta 2 first you sparked
quite a reaction
in the scientific community when you
wrote this letter this week with other
scientists too
arguing that coveted restrictions should
be targeted at the most
vulnerable what exactly is the argument
there
the argument there is that the best way
we can protect lives both of those who
are vulnerable to covid
and those who are vulnerable to the
measures that we're taking
to protect ourselves from kovid covid is
by
allowing the infection to spread among
those
who are not vulnerable such that
immunity is built up in the population
which then brings the risk of infection
down
let's say by christmas for example um
to those who are vulnerable to covid and
in the process
during that period when immunity is
going to be built up and we
don't know how much immunity we need to
build up we previously suggested that
there
is already some substantial amounts of
immunity in the population
but you know we don't know that but
let's if we take the measure
of the view that okay we don't know how
much immunity there is
but we do know that we can build up
enough immunity
to keep the risks low so why not go
ahead and do that and meanwhile
aggressively shield the vulnerable
population
i guess one of the questions would be
how easy or desirable it would be to
shield
the vulnerable for the amount of time
you're talking about it could be
millions of people
and professor riley what's your view
on the ideas put forward by professor
gupta there
so professor gupta has raised three
different issues there which i think we
should
make sure that we get through in the
time available we talked about the
existing community
um how long it might take if we if we
did go for some kind of population
immunity strategy
and she's also talked about whether uh
shielding's effective i think the first
thing that i would really like to deal
with is whether we know how much
immunity
or not there is in the uk um and and we
really do
so we've got very good zero surveys um
that have measured
the national prevalence for england at
13 and for london
at six percent and we use very similar
techniques there to techniques that have
just been used in brazil
in places that probably have achieved
population immunity and have had a
terrible time in that process
and with very similar techniques they
measure 60 percent
so we've got six percent and in
communities london has 13
and in communities in brazil that have
probably achieved population immunity
they are at 60 percent
okay um let's go back to professor gupta
because you obviously did the study
didn't you in march suggesting that half
of people in the uk may have already had
covert i mean that's now thought to be
quite
wrong isn't it i mean do you have
concerns about the levels of immunity
needed
i think that first of all i should say
that we do not
know what level of immunity we have in
the population
um as someone who has whose laboratory
has produced
one of the tests that we've been using
to assess
um the serial prevalence of covid i
think
i can say that we've been through a long
journey here and what we know
first of all the two things to be said
here one is that antibody levels
fall so we can't tell from people
from antibiotic prevalence what
proportion are immune
antibody levels antibodies aren't made
by everybody
the levels fall some people are
protected because they already have
immunity
in place either through previous
exposure to curvid or
for other reasons we know now that the
picture is much more complex
with so so we don't know we cannot tell
from zero prevalence
what proportion population has been
exposed certainly not
if they've been exposed six months
beforehand that is already clear
basic population epidemiology tells you
that even if the herd immunity threshold
is low in the first peak you will have a
significant
overshoot so the idea that sixty percent
measures of sixty percent or many other
measures of that ilk that are being
found in
for example dharavi and sums of bombay
in various settings do not indicate
that the herd immunity threshold is 60
that is simply not true okay and
clearly some disagreement there about
the levels of immunity
and professor riley i guess some
people's argument
would be that there is a cost of
lockdown that needs to be calculated
and really brought into how we decide to
uh you know
tackle the virus going forward are you
concerned that there may be a point when
actually the costs of the restrictions
whether it is
people not coming forward to the nhs as
they want to or people's mental health
um may outweigh the cost of suppressing
the virus and the way that we are
absolutely and and not for a moment do i
believe there are any
easy decisions at the moment um it's
it's a very difficult time i have to
i have to pick up one more point um from
professor gupta
we have to stop saying herd immunity
it's population immunity we have to be
we we have to be really clear that is
occurring that places in the world they
have population immunity
um the there
this is being presented as a choice
between a very difficult lockdown
and a rapid return to relatively normal
life with
some extra deaths i don't believe that's
a reasonable representation of the
choice
what we have is a choice between us
deciding to reduce our social contact so
that this does not spread as quickly
or the virus will decide it for us the
lockdown was
especially difficult in the uk because
we had the virus
and the lock down so we had we were
scared of the virus and we couldn't go
out because we were scared of the virus
and we were being asked to lock down
right now levels of fear about the virus
are lower because we've kept it low
during the summer
if we don't reduce the number of social
contacts
in a very short period of time we're
going to be dealing with
restrictive measures and we're going to
be dealing with much higher levels of
fear about the virus
and professor gupta do you think that is
you know a fair argument that actually
we all need to start reducing our social
contacts in order to get the virus under
control
um no i don't think so i think we need a
sensible discussion about this because
um you know i mean what our common goal
is to protect the vulnerables we know
that
what we're talking about here is the
most efficient way to do that
and that obviously will involve some
level
of social distancing it's a question of
how to apportion that in the population
and and whether we can have an age
stratified strategy really
to achieve what i'm sure is a common
goal so you know i i agree
i think with a lot of what stephen is
saying in the you know maybe we should
avoid terms like her
immunity and and we should think very
carefully about
uh what sort of pro social distancing
measures we need
in place who to distance how to distance
them and what
really we're calling for is an open
discussion because i i know that
you know stephen and i want the same
thing we're just
we're coming at it from different views
viewpoints and what we need to do is sit
around the table
and have a discussion a really open
discussion
about how we can get there let's look at
the costs of lockdown
let's look at the various costs of
social distancing and come up with an
optimal strategy
that's all we're arguing for it's not a
matter of being right
or wrong or our scientific reputations i
think we're
long past that what we really want to do
right now is to prevent a situation
whereby students are locked up in
university halls that's
all we want to prevent i'm sure we all
have the same goal there
but i i think that
an efficient solution would be to
protect the vulnerable so to put efforts
into sealing off
but not sealing off but you know finding
a way for people in care homes to not be
infected
so we can uh obviously go out and test
people coming to the care homes while
you visit
someone as frail and elderly as that you
might take
really serious precautions but in the
meantime i think we can allow
children to go to school without any
restrictions
universities to go back and for halls
not to shut down just because there's
been
an outbreak amongst a group of people
who aren't at risk
i think as a university teacher i am
prepared to take
what little risk there is uh additional
risk to my
life to go out and teach students face
to face
i think we should be prepared to do that
so i
having said that i don't want an 85 year
old
to succumb to this disease so the
question is how do we
optimize given the landscape of risks
that we're
now slowly starting to understand a
little bit better
and the costs of lockdown which you know
lockdown is destructive we have to
accept that and then the conversation
can continue i think you're absolutely
right to you know underline the point
that all anyone wants is to try and find
the best way of
suppressing the virus the best way of
going forward as well and it's good to
have an open discussion
on the programme this morning too and
professor riley
do you think it's realistic this idea
that you could effectively
segregate the population and and keep
the
most vulnerable shielded i think there's
there's two slightly different issues
here we need to do the very best job we
can
to shield the most vulnerable regardless
of the rest of the policy
that's an independent problem we need to
be testing as frequently as possible in
care and workers and healthcare staff i
absolutely agree with that
but no 18 of the uk population is over
the age of 65.
if they're going to have some contacts
there's going to be a layer of younger
people and
other high-risk people outside of them
we're up to a really
big proportion of the uk population it
it doesn't make sense in in two ways
it's such a large proportion
um that effectively you know getting
towards half of us are going to be
locked down anyway
so we're trying to live in a kind of
bipartite way
um and then it's so difficult it's
it's not going to be quick if we were to
adopt an entirely liberal approach and
let the virus decide our social
structure
it's not going to be a very rapid thing
it's going to last for a long time and i
think
i agree with sinetra that we need a
really open debate about this and the
people that are recommending that we
don't agree our social contacts for
ourselves
the people who are agreeing that we just
let people make individual decisions
they need to be really clear
about how long they expect there to be a
high number of deaths per day
what they expect the number of deaths
per day to reach and they need to be
clear about how
full intensive care units are going to
be for how long
so people will know how they're going to
feel about the healthcare service i
totally agree we need an open debate but
we need
both sides to be very clear about what
they believe the implications will be
of the different choices well let's put
that to professor gupta shall we and
how long do you think the strategy could
go on for how long would people have to
shield forward and what kind of rate of
death would you expect to see
that that's um you know that that's
absolutely the the right point
is that i think one has to take on board
this is not
permanent this is a temporary solution
i mean a temporary measure that we need
to make to affect permanent
solution so between now and christmas
if we take try and think very carefully
about how we can protect
the people who are actually vulnerable
to death from infection
and in the meantime allow those who are
not vulnerable
to mix particularly in a university
setting which is
effectively you know somewhat sealed off
from the general population at least in
my own university experience
i think we can come up with strategies
we need to exactly as stephen says sit
down
and think about this and this is not
about liberalism this is not a liberal
the notion that what i'm proposing is a
sort of libertarian position
is is really to me very very um
upsetting
i don't think that's the case at all um
i think that this is the communitarian
this is what a welfare state
should consider we need to protect
everybody including those who are
vulnerable to lockdown
who are the poor the disadvantaged the
young
that has to be i think our priority
and then that in mind i think we can
construct
strategies where we introduce social
distancing which is commensurate with
their risk
for the proportion of the population
above since the age of 5. that's fine
i'm going to have to
come in so i'm keen to go back to um
professor reilly before we have to leave
it there
and what's any reaction to what
professor gupta was saying and also
of course there is as we were saying a
cost to restrictions too how long do you
expect the restrictions
to have to go on for until we might
start to see some light at the end of
the tunnel
um i think um firstly i
i think while professor gupta may not be
uh and
thinking about this in a kind of
libertarian framework i think our
experience from observing around the
world is that is
a large part of the debate uh in many
places
um and i think that we the the
the strategy that's being outlined
um for probably the next six months
is that we have to learn the most
effective ways
of keeping transmission down to low
levels
whilst keeping schools open so i think i
think
most people who are imagining how these
are gonna
pan out in the future are seeing a six
month time horizon within which
we have the possibility but by no means
the guarantee
of some support from a vaccine but it is
very
reasonable to expect massively improved
testing over that timeline
and then some of the statistics that
have been mentioned earlier in the show
today statistics about household
isolation
not being effective when we have very
high volume
very rapid testing those basic building
blocks of public health for infectious
diseases
get much much more effective so
there are a number of things that we
expect to improve
substantially in the next six months